now let's deal with this Delta H okay
now Delta H is a bit weird and that's
what this second diagram is for okay at
the moment unfortunately well I mean
precisely because I have made this slice
as infinitely thin as I can on my
diagram I can't really work out like
this distance is so on this second
diagram I want us to imagine if we
actually blew out those aged so it was
big okay we don't want it to be big but
if it's big we can actually work with it
and try and understand the geometry
behind this okay so here's what I'm
going to do remember we have this point
a so I'm just going to stick it over
here say X Y that Delta H it's actually
the distance of a little cord so i want
you to make that cord a bit bigger right
if it's a cause that means it joins two
points on the circumference right so
I've not one of them already I just need
another one that's called it be okay now
this is interesting I could have gone up
to the circle or I could have gone down
the circle it doesn't matter all that
much now that I've got be right the
whole idea is that it's a little
distance away from a small distance now
going along this axis I'm calling out
Delta H but here I need some coordinates
right I need some coordinates so I need
an x and y that are a little bit away
from a which is X 1 so i'll give you the
easy one first this B point it's clearly
higher than a right so it's like the y
coordinate plus a little extra way right
I already have language from when I talk
about a little bit extra on a certain
axis I'm gonna call that y plus Delta Y
okay just just go up a little bit now
it's a bit unusual to start with the
wise the reason why is because going
from A to B I'm going up so that's why i
added Delta Y but when i go from A to B
on this particular configuration which
way do I go 4x answer to the left right
so in fact this is not X plus Delta X
unless someone don't xv- that's just
confusing
I'm just going to say it's ex take away
a little bit I'll go to the left okay I
have to because I'm up stole this a
computer server ok this is pretty much
all we need I want you to see when would
Delta H be on this diagram if that's
where a and B are which are kind of like
the top and bottom of my bottom and top
of my little infinitesimally thin
cylinder ok these things are going to
extend to be perpendicular to make
access of rotation yes and what I've
done is that's part of the cross section
that area is the bit that's being
rotated around to give me my cylinder do
you agree with that so then when you
look at this thing the Delta H that I
Martha is actually here do you see it
it's this distance on long dis actors ok
now i can work out Delta H I can I've
got all the information that I need to
but I'm going to pull a bit of a
calculus trip because they're dealing he
would dump it when dealing with very
very tiny things you can approximately
when you're dealing with very small
things in the same way that to develop
the derivatives for sine cos and tan we
took advantage of this for small values
of x right do you remember that we
needed this limit this kind of limiting
behavior to do all of the first
principles I'm going to do exactly the
same thing here Delta H right this this
is actually quite awkward to get but a
distance it's easy to get is this cord a
be a look at that cord a bit how am I
work out that distance I could do the
distance for not there's an even easier
way the discus form is built on
Pythagoras is it not it's built on
Pythagoras ok so that means that between
every pair of points your interest in
the distance there is a little right
angle triangle yes but the way we got a
and B was to define the sides of that
little triangle right it's little
because the X
is a little bit of X Delta X and the y
part is a little bit of why not why ok
are you staying with me are you on track
yes ok so what I'm going to say is i can
continue don't get rid of this sine X
please I worked out our before now I'm
on the trail of working out Delta H ok
so i'm going to say Delta H well it's
not exactly equal to you but on these
tiny tiny scales it is close enough to a
be that I can work with it ok as Delta H
gets smaller a B will get small in
exactly the same way like imagine
imagine Delta H moving about and it's
always going to correspond to a B&B
roughly the same ok it's much limit
equal to a be but i'm just going to use
pythagoras to work out what a BS right
what's the side length side lengths
rather of that writing betrayal wait
what yeah I both know I thought I had a
crazy where I wasn't expecting I'm dr. X
is one of the shorter sides and Delta Y
is one of the other ones now again I'm
going to pull another trick which may be
honestly I know the first time I don't
do this I was not that comfortable with
it I want you to notice but even though
it's not exactly so this little right
angle triangle here has to exist inside
of this big right angle triangle here do
you see that like imagine the biggest a
beer you could the biggest aber you
could it's going to be the original cord
do you agree with that and as a bee gets
smaller and smaller it's still going to
be patterned after this big version this
boy be a or b would be the name of that
triangle right but the thing about a OB
is what kind of triangle is it's not
just right angle it's also my social
things it's also I sauce on it now this
trailer is not isosceles but but I don't
need it to be exactly our sauce elite I
only
close enough when Delta X gets small
what's going to happen to del Y it will
also become small so therefore because
I'm in this approximate infinitesimal
world I can say that this is Delta x
squared and another delta x square now I
am doing this not just because it's
simpler why am I getting Delta H in the
first place what is this going to be
useful for this is the height of this
cylinder nice long alias in this case
cuz no hole in the middle but eventually
I'm going to add up a whole bunch of
these and then I'm going to integrate
right I want to eat to make with respect
to a single variable because I don't
know how else to integrate yeah so
wherever I see multiple variables I want
to get away from them I'm eventually
going to get away from this one as well
but I'm not ready for that yet okay can
we tidy this up what are we going to get
out of this I can take out a stack to
all the square root of Delta x squared
which is Delta X don't swear at the
absolute value because of course Delta X
is positive and then you've got a route
to hanging in there do you see that you
need adjustable not really this is one
of those extension to case by inspection
type questions right there's so many
other things going on in this question
I'm looking ok now do you see this is
hugely important right do you remember
we started we're like oh it's more on
this access is not on that axis but now
I have a relationship between access I
am rotating around and an access I can
integrate on right does that make sense
so this is really really good I'm pretty
much ready to assemble my pieces now I
can actually do this ok I'm going to get
rid of this guy I don't need anymore I
want to make a statement like this right
limiting behavior some of a whole bunch
of things but I want to make it for what
I now know to be the case